permette ai sogni dentro la saponetta
ma perché le mie scarpe così al muro un
portale e costruttive tornati sani
terrestre oggi nuovo video di trucchetti
us tour di stupidi inutili o
semplicemente trani mela testi richiesti
in tantissimi da quando ho fatto gli
ultimi due video un punto in cui
andavamo a vedere i trucchetti più
strani che ci sono su youtube e
cercavamo di capire a cosa servissero
quindi e desideri parlando perché
coordinate a richiedere melo e appunto
ho salvato fare i video in cui ci sono
dei trucchetti che alcuni non capisco
cosa servono o alcuni sono stranissimi
andremo a vederle atene oggi il video
divertente che di ho messo il mio
braccialetto
lol giallo siete pronti mettetevi comodi
pop corn e patatine lasciato un bel
laica questo video è iniziamo subito è
ovvio mi fiori il mio bottone che
premerò quando ci sono i trucchetti più
assurdi o i più divertenti
ok allora in questo trucchetto st
presenti giubbotti e di plastica e la
saggezza e infine schiene dell'etichetta
e questo se non hai un cestino della
modesta semplicemente mi sono buttata
cataneo con dello scotch
ok prossimo questo è un video del
famosissimo canale five minutes fra e a
225 milioni di visualizzazioni quindi
suppongo che
ci saranno dei trucchetti utilissimi
geniali che servono a tutti e che
funzionano vero vediamo sta ritagliando
una bottiglia di shampoo credo vediamo
cosa fa a creare un porta spugna che
consola tenda e non è male questo dai
non è male meglio di quello che esca per
fare due figli è sicuramente poi prende
un contenitore di pringles lara
rivestito e si mette dentro dei bellezza
a mettere struccati al che abbia pulito
prima ma vabbè io personalmente non
userei questo trucchetto
prende poi un topo e ma importante
giusto ma in un porta spazzolino appeso
al muro
[Musica]
sinceramente io trovo abbastanza brutto
ditemi voi nei commenti se vuoi piazze
poi una bottiglia di plastica intorno al
distanza produttivi di plastica ma
questo non l'avevo già fatto un porta ma
ma chi serve questo senso come di
venturi in mente certe né allora udine
cosa che cola la sta riempiendo con
nello shop quando ho fatto qualcosa di
simile io ho fatto il sapone per le mani
alla coca cola questo non l idea è
infatti l'ho fatto anch'io questo per
avere un po diverso era alla coca cola
poi ma aspetta perché si sono moneta
dall'uomo scusate questo non l'ho capita
spiegatemelo voi ho fatto che io ogni
tanto
in mezzo si sono dei trucchetti che non
capisco proprio perché è usare un
contenitore quando puoi usare una
boccetta di sapone per mettere le cose
in volta vediamo questa è per trichet sf
con le mollette
un porta ma ma perché dovreste appendere
le tre carte al muro ma per pulite
almeno se non sai che bel profumo nella
stanza a perché non così una teglia
fermarsi per organizzare le cose del tuo
cassetto non ci avevo mai pensato
vediamoci ma perché le vie per unity
scarpe così auguro sono sporche ha detto
entra in casa c strisci stop roma che
qualcuno ci offende pure la giacca per
sbaglio no dei five minutes card da te
qualcosa di bello e interessante con bio
bottiglie o portava cosa su cui mi
spiega messo una bottiglia d'acqua nel
caminetto per utilizzare meno acqua sta
andando male per mini france e questo
video successo che 5 milioni di views
voglio capire il perché voglio vedere
quali sono questi tool che si getta
anche allora sta dipingendo una
forchetta di plastica
vediamo cosa creano adesso
un orologio con forchette di plastica e
cucchiaini colorati baber meno questo è
un po più creativi fianco l'altra fa con
questa forchetta la piegata a ok ha
creato un cacciavite da una forchetta e
troppo utile che per viva
ok sta aprendo una tossina in modo molto
strano con un cucchiaio ma perché perché
allora un panno lo sta piegando questo è
bello questo bello questo ci piace ma
perché dovresti fare ma perché dovresti
mettere una cambierà d'un fiato con una
forchetta questa si mette al pulsante
tra l'altro articolo tutta la sera ma il
piatto 9
ok st mette il beneficio nella scarpa
vediamo perché non riesco a immaginare
perché dovresti mettere 20 feature
dentro la scarpa ma vediamo al sacco le
mogli scattolini quindi non determini io
voglio vedere i denti bridge nella
scarpa 20 brizzi
ok questo è un fatto in via di pulire le
scarpe con il dentifricio tanto tempo fa
l'ho fatto e funziona però non dentro la
scarpa
voglio vedere dentro
beh non ti metto dentro la scarpa marco
vento lo aspettavo dopo il trucchetto
forse arriva costa tra parlando una
saponetta l'attenzione perché per
mettere i soldi dentro la saponetta cosa
io lo metterei mai i sistemisti dentro
uno stoppone nascosta nei bagagli di un
certo poi magari si scioglie e attaccata
ai soldi e ma io vorrei sapere se ci
sono da meno persone che utilizzano
questi trucchetti
voi avete mai utilizzato uno di questi
trucchetti di questo canale
ditelo nei commenti sono troppo curiosa
ditemi se ne avete mai utilizzato
qualcuno e se ha funzionato soprattutto
vorrei fare un video in cui il tetto
sono i trucchetti più assurdi per vedere
che se funzionano ma ci sta per essere
ok regala il secondo mi interessa molto
allora se non un bagno nella banca e
testato un in cui passa il dentifricio
sopra il telefono e lo pulisce bene
dicono ma nella copertina di questo
video c'era un telefono spaccato lo
schermo spaccato e loro che
riuscivano a togliere le crepe con la
gomma da cancellare o con i piedi friso
vediamo quale in realtà questo
trucchetto non mette nel riso
[Musica]
cos'è io sto aspettando il trucchetto in
cui cancelli le crepe nel telefono con
la gomma da cancellare e con il
dentifricio dunque essere dietro totti
li ho trovati
io ho trovato due che fanno questo
trucchetto vediamo se funziona e come lo
fanno allora il numero uno
allora non mi sembra spaccato questo
schermo mi sembra solo sporco ma vediamo
che succede
[Musica]
sta spalmando il 20 ferito colpito così
va beh sicuramente dopo il telefono
problema era tanti e poi sta continuando
a spalmare tutto con la caratese che
[Musica]
[Applauso]
hanno sempre tutti queste canzoni di
sottofondo belli o click day cruiser ben
9000 e tutte c'è in pratica
nell'immagine di copertina fatto vedere
lo schermo spaccato e che metteva il
dentifricio ma in realtà lo schermo
spaccato era lo sfondo dello schermo ok
questo non mi sembra spaccato non ci
credo anche questo ho messo uno sfondo
l'immagine di uno schermo spaccato come
sfondo non è spaccato lo schermo come
sono veramente
la corte non ci posso credere
[Musica]
wow e dentifricio ha magicamente
riparato il telefono o kay la super
questo dello schermo spaccato e
arriviamo questi perché c'è scritto che
questi sono truccati stupidi ma che
funzionano
vediamo allora un temperino e una gomma
ha preso la forma del temperino volta in
tagliando con la roma che cosa vorrà
fare secondo voi già non mi convince
questa volta non vediamo se ci sorprende
the ok ha intagliato il tutto e allora
sta mettendo il la colla attak super
attak e sta incollata del temperino alla
gomma
perché
[Applauso]
[Musica]
e ora tempera con la gomma attaccato ma
perché qual è il motivo stoffa che tutti
noi che così si è il delfino che la
gomma con fare prima a cancellare
temperare cosa mi dispiace ma anche
questo vince il voto 8
vediamo con questo studio è italiano che
qua la spugna incredibile in questi
trucchetti la taglierina c'è sempre
vediamo cosa infilerà dentro la spugna
lo spazzolino perché perché no ma
spiegatemi perchè perchè che cos'è un e
un copri spazzolino
a parte che la spugna assorbe quindi se
lo spazzolino e bagnato penalizzato
assorbe tutto
che ha un passato questo fondi ok ora
fatti questi foglietti si mette nel
contenitore per gomme da masticare
[Musica]
rimette le gomme dentro tutti fosse ho
capito non mi dire che così lucia non
gradire
[Musica]
no è ancora peggio di quanto quest'arte
i foglietti c'è tutto questo trucchetto
che è durato tantissimo e perché quando
messinscena gomma lo metti del foglietto
narratori del foglietto ok ragazzi
cambiamo video qua dice che questi
trucchetti sono geniali
vediamo subito inviato libro che ha
preso una cannuccia la tagliata e
riempendo una siringa di dentifricio e
sta riempiendo il pezzo di camicia team
dentifricio che è ora lo sta richiudendo
ok per portarti il 20 fregio in viaggio
forse ma la scomodità di questa cosa
vabbè magari qualcuno che non riesce a
trovare un tubetto di dentifricio o meno
di 100 ml ma durò una volta quanti ne
che mi pare di prossimo sacchetto di
patatine dai dimmi che questo trucchetto
e geniale onore chiude ma non chiude
[Applauso]
quindi un elastico ma come fate ad
essere un trucchetto spiega ottenere
come fa sto partendo da sperava li
vediamo vuole anche lui nascondere il
suo di mentre post it sa premiare la
forma
ok pensi di aver capito vuole nascondere
questi dieci dollari
dentro i posti ebbene si ragazzi
se volete nascondere i costrizioni
dentro un blocchetto di post it
qualsiasi sia il motivo che io non
capisco è come farlo ok non ce la faccio
più ultimo trucchetto ultimo perfetto
perché non ce l'ha fatto che fa abbiamo
del burro nemiche questo un trucchetto
del centro frega sta sfornando il burro
con un coltello troppo grosso per
formare il burro
[Applauso]
[Musica]
dice no perché perché il coltello troppo
grosso no non ci posso credere veramente
ha ricoperto il coltello di pellicola
trasparente ma perché per sporche
credere perché non faccio così vestita
fare i piatti ricopriamo tutto con una
pellicola trasparente così poi dobbiamo
lavare niente ci basta solo togliere la
pellicola tantissimo tra lastricare
questi trucchetti però ho un vincitore
il vincitore per me è il primo
trucchetto per cioè quello di crearsi
delle scarpe da tre puccini quello è
stato veramente etico scrivetemi voi nei
commenti secondo voi chi è il vincitore
di questo video e fatemi sapere se
volete vedere alterazioni a trucchetti
terribili o non lo so geniali li troverò
primo popoli si possono sapere e
lasciato un bel laica questo video è ora
io vi lascio con altre quattro
cartellini di cui potete cliccare se
volete vedere altri tutti gli stupidi
altri video divertenti anche challenge
scegliete quello che preferite e buona
visione
[Musica]